the Sanders and sisters are back for a
nostalgic fun-filled sequel stacked with
Easter eggs and deep cut references to
the original movie yupikai movie lovers
I'm Jan and I've been re-watching and
pausing Hocus Pocus 2 to uncover all the
amazing little details you might have
missed the movie begins with a wicked
flashback to Salem 1653 and winifred's
16th birthday and a creepy spider that
young Sarah gives to Winnie you will
love it it's a Sly reference to Sarah's
love of spiders in the original movie
what a pretty spider the costume
Department also honored Sarah's
affection for the creepy crawlies on her
new costume which has sleeves made to
look like crocheted spiders webs and if
you look really closely you'll spot some
spiders embroidered among the floral and
Thorn design on her bodice after fleeing
the Salem mob into the Forbidden Woods
the three young sisters form a calming
Circle and amusingly think about the
reverence screaming and other
deliciously terrible things things
soothing thoughts smell of fresh mud the
reference screamed when he saw the
spider this moment calls back to how the
adult sandersons form a circle when
they're stressed out in the first movie
and the hilariously awful things they
think about rabbit beds Black Death
mummy scorpion pie become little
children tuned that the young sisters
here in the woods is the same one in the
original film and notice how it's young
Sarah who becomes entranced by the song
reflecting the fact that she's the one
who'll sing it to lure the children of
Salem over 400 years later now pay close
attention to the witch mother in her
costume in this scene as the embroidered
eye on her outfit reappears many times
throughout the movie it's a reference to
the eye on the spell book that she gives
to Winnie and Winifred also has eyes
embroidered on her costume when she
returns later on The Broach around the
witch mother's neck is also identical to
the one used as Winnie's belt buckle and
the stones match the color of each of
their outfits moving on to present-day
Salem and the name of the school Becca
Izzy and Cassie go to is Samuel Skelton
the name of a real-life Puritan who
settled in Salem and founded the first
church in the town and notice when Izzy
arrives the scarf she's wearing is
covered in eyes another creepy little
reference to book while Becca is waiting
outside the principal's office the
assistant may be wearing a ladybird
outfit but these look a lot like Mickey
or Minnie Mouse hands in the sequel we
discovered the Sanderson sister's old
home has been converted into Gilbert's
Old Salem magic shop and The Cauldron of
cats filled with stuffed toy black cats
is likely a nod to Thackery Banks who
knocked over the witch's cauldron filled
with potion in the first movie and was
transformed into a black cat there's
also a ton of Sanders and sisters
merchandise in the shop including these
doll versions of them here when Gilbert
reveals the book of spells to his
audience at the shop pause and look
really closely at the straps holding
book down in particular the Little Grill
over the eye which is a deliberate
homage to Hannibal lecter's mouth
restraint in Silence of the Lambs and
the costume that Gilbert was during his
presentation his eyes on both the hat
and the cloak referencing book plus
there are eyes on the door he emerges
through here after Becca and Izzy arrive
at the shop you'll need to pause really
quickly here to spot the Houdini poster
on the wall when cobweb appears out of
nowhere the question do spirits return
is some sneaky foreshadowing for how
Becca and Izzy who are also in this shot
will accidentally bring the Sanderson
sisters back to life later on it's an
awesome moment when the sisters finally
return with Winnie slapping both Sarah
and Mary in the stomach in a deliberate
hat tip to how she gut punched Sarah in
the original movie
the song they sing here the witches are
back is an amusing take on Elton John's
the [ __ ] is back after the trio catch
Becca and Izzy the girls player trick on
them pretending their witches too we
only look young but really we're 40. oh
40. I'm Physicians this reminds me of
how Max played a ruse to escape the
witches in the original movie you mess
with the Great and Powerful Max summon
the burning reign of death
[Music]
film weather
believe they contain The Souls of
deceased children is a deep cut
reference to a deleted scene from the
first movie delicious
his tinkly my favorite feeling so far
the full deleted scene hasn't been
released but one of the original
trailers for the 1993 movie does show
Mary Downing various liquids in a
supermarket and looking to eat a child
and the sister's funny walk they do as
they explore the store is a call back to
the walk they did after they came back
to life in the first movie
Becca Izzy and Cassie also pay homage to
the walk at the end of the movie when
they suddenly find themselves doing it
without realizing when Becca and Izu
salt to protect themselves and the
sister's dark magic it's a nod to how
Alison used salt in the first movie and
given Becca turns out to be a witch in
the sequel and Winnie remarked about
Alison
it adds to the popular fan theory that
Alison was a secret witch herself all
along the brooms and sisters fly off on
in the sequel get a fun update to Modern
cleaning and vacuum Tech in 2022
compared to the 1993 movie Sarah gets an
upgraded mop and Mary finds a pair of
robot vacuums which also play a crucial
role later on when they break the salt
Circle keeping them trapped at the Trask
household now if you're wondering why
Mary says cowabunga as she flies off
it's a wink to kathina Jimmy's role as
the voice of the mayor of which town in
the rise of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle show and as the three hatch their
plan which ends up being suspiciously
similar to the one in the first movie
Sarah responds to Winnie with a line
from the original film
that's the first step in this scheme is
to return to their old Cottage and the
way the door swings open amid flashes of
light is a tribute to the same way they
returned in the first movie this time
though Sarah is disappointed at the
state of the place where are the Cowboys
and my rat tails this is an amusing nod
the first thing she did in the OG movie
after arriving back my lucky ratel and
the way she goes searching for her rat
tails by hanging from the rafters is a
throwback to when she swung from the
cemetery gates in the original movie
Sarah's response to Gilbert revealing
himself to the trio a boy is a shout out
to the three sisters reaction when they
first saw Thackery Banks oh boy
as well as to Sarah's generally boy
crazy ways back in the 90s boys will
love me when Gilbert tells the sisters
he saw them on Halloween night in 1993.
he mentions a bunch of boys stole his
candy referencing the bullies Jay and
Ice who harassed Max and Danny for their
Halloween candy in the original movie
and the empty cloth container that
Gilbert used for his candy also looks
like it's probably this Mickey and
Minnie Mouse pillowcase there's some
fantastic store names at the scare fest
such as Apple plectic which is a play on
the word apoplectic and a store where
participants have to Bob for apples
they're drowning a man how Charming
there's also lifestyles of the witch and
famous a nod to the 80s and 90s reality
TV series Lifestyles of the Rich and
Famous and there's a bon appetit and
Grave e food stall with a wicked witch
selling poisoned Apple strolling by in a
reference to Disney's Snow White and
while mer Trask is waiting in line for
his caramel apple there's a man behind
him dressed like the devil and a woman
wearing a dressing gown and rollers in
her hair These Are A sly reference to
the scene from the first movie when the
sisters thought they were meeting their
Master Satan himself and also met his
wife who was getting ready for bed at
the time
see the snakes and the scene with that
couple from the first film actually
appears when Winnie stumbles across
another couple watching the original
Hocus Pocus movie The fact the events of
the first film exist as a movie and this
universe shows just how famous the
Sanderson sisters are in that world just
like the first movie The Sisters sing a
song at the Halloween festival in the
sequel I bet you're looking for the
stage always and if you pause here
there's some nice details for the
various other acts like the broom
Brigade the acrobats and Hades hotties
which is a reference to the Greek god of
the underworld who's the villain in
Disney's 90s movie Hercules when the
sisters Put a Spell on the scare fest
audience and have them dance down the
street there's a definite Vibe of the
music video for Michael Jackson's
Thriller there's also some great Easter
eggs in the crowd such as this lady
wearing a Madonna outfit a reference to
the costume worn by Max and Danny's mum
on Halloween night and it also looks
like someone's wearing the sorcerer
Mickey Mouse hat from Fantasia after the
sisters discover Becca hiding Winnie
can't remember her name oh what's her
name again
which is the same thing Mary calls Danny
when she finds her in the first movie
which is a pun on the food Shish kebaby
as Trask arrives back home to find the
sisters trapped in his garage he gets
out of his car and when he calls it a
very small bus an amusing reference to
the first encounter with most rise
transport in the first movie What is
this contraction I call it a bus when
Sarah and Mary fade into dust as a price
Winnie pays for the magikai Maxima spell
they say goodbye in the same way they
bade farewell after the sun came up in
the first film
although Billy says the final
destruction of the sisters is what has
now released him from the curses placed
on him by Winnie if you watch to the
very end of the credits there's a bonus
scene where cobweb reveals that Gilbert
has a second black flame candle in his
possession which means we could easily
see the Sanderson sisters return again
for a third movie let me know what you
think about that and any other comments
below if you love Disney movies tap here
for another video just like this and if
you enjoyed this video do leave a thumbs
up I really appreciate it thanks for
enjoying this movie with me and hope you
have a marvelous movie loving week
yupikai movie lovers